[Music]
we're living in a world right now where
we have more data than we know what to
do with almost right and so then we turn
that corner to what are those insights
what are those specific tools what's
that specific leverage that we can get
to our customers and that's really I
think what we wake up every day and try
to put that thinking cap on and
empathize with the end golfer try to
solve problems for them they might not
even know they have
there's been an explosion of data so
data on how different golf balls fly
data on how golfers move around the
course
and then layer on top of that
intelligent analytics on what does that
data mean
and so we now need to figure out how to
take that data take those measurements
analyze it and ultimately extract
insights to help people play better golf
enjoy the game more and that requires
tools and structures to help us not only
process and and analyze that data but
then also deliver it to the end user and
and help the customer understand and
leverage those insights that we're
getting from these new measurements and
new technologies it's amazing what smart
people can accomplish with good tools
but then being able to take that
and quickly turn it into a production
grade commercially viable web app and
get that up to the public was
that was a big win and since then we've
taken that momentum and repeated it
several more times I think we're just at
the very beginning of being able to
bring this collection of tools to the
everyday golfer
[Music]
so I was introduced to Ping through a
colleague who was a designer here and I
got in started working part-time in the
manufacturing Engineering Group and I
just loved the culture I love solving
problems I never envisioned that I would
use my engineering degree to even get
into golf design so it's been a very fun
Journey because I've been able to invest
time in my game follow my passion get
better at golf join the PGA of America
and that's opened up some doors to play
competitive tournament golf but when
that door opened to get in here I loved
it I loved the culture I love learning
about all the unknowns all the golf
physics that was there in the Curiosity
I was an r d engineer he was a designer
he always has just been really consumed
with what the customer needs how do I
help somebody play the game more and I
was more on the research side trying to
help answer the questions that he was
posing I think that culture
of being so curious about how things
work and then being able to kind of take
ownership to try to solve a problem and
then ultimately turn it into a solution
for the customer right
um and and I love that as I started
working here at ping I started playing
golf more and more and that became more
of a passion for me even outside of my
time here on campus doing the
engineering things and it's really
helped me understand the elements of the
game that are a challenge the pain of a
player trying to get better and it's
really helped me understand how to ask
the right research questions and and
tackle the right areas to help make golf
equipment better A lot of new people got
introduced to golf during the past few
years and so there's kind of a younger
generation a network of golfers that
previously weren't introduced to the
gamer out there and so we've tried to
just really both from a product
standpoint from a custom fitting
standpoint and try to continue that
momentum
[Music]
ping was founded by a frustrated
engineer Karsten solheim he founded the
company because he looked at how
equipment was designed and said hey I
could bring my engineering background
and make the game way easier through
some fundamental you know physics
principles and it's still kind of in the
DNA of ping in what we do every company
develops little centers of excellence
groups of one or two folks who who try
to solve a problem the best way they can
or the the best way they know how and
one of those that had developed at ping
that I learned about was a group in
engineering that we're using the r
programming language to help visualize
and share insights and information about
golf data and how we do business
initially we started looking at shiny
apps to help just visualize and quickly
draw insights from data that we acquired
on a range here through player testing
from a motion capture system shiny apps
at ping really are where the first value
from r
came out you know that's that's Dr
Henriksen and Marty and their teams who
are the clever folks behind those a lot
of these physics-based and data-driven
models that we were developing we were
developing them using pause at our
studio then using like the shiny
framework developing these dashboards
for our Engineers to then use these
models and use the data we get from
player testing and motion capture
testing to design equipment and so we
went to Doug and we're like hey we have
these models we're using this shiny
framework to develop these shiny
dashboards and apps to kind of beta test
some different ideas we have for for
tools that would help both Engineers as
well as the end consumer Dr Hendrickson
and his team had identified r as
something they wanted to work on and
something they wanted to do and they had
built a handful of shiny applications
but they did it without the support of
it and without the support of the larger
corporate digital strategy because they
had to they were solving a problem they
were innovating so I was glad to be able
to to come in and say that's fantastic
but that doesn't scale let's try some
some other techniques and that's where
posit connect came in as not only
providing us the ability to to publish
these tools that we're developing but
also host apis and help us move toward
consumer facing applications where we
can then build out a front end and then
hook that into these apis and posit
connect the big proof of value came the
first time that I convinced them to
instead of creating a shiny app create a
plumber API and then can I share that
plumber API with a team within pengu can
build a web interface around it and
publish that to the public and that that
really was the like okay this is gonna
work instead of rebuilding all of our
algorithms and fundamental modeling
we're able to use apis that drive that
front end that our customers experience
with without having to rebuild our
prototype we just built our front end
right on top of it posit connect gives a
tool set to program real
json-based apis that's fundamental if
you can't do that you're gonna have a
really hard time working with
any other system how it works is that
we take those models and then we're able
to create and now logic and develop some
apis uh and and through the plumber
framework and through connect host those
and and then provide this foundation for
other tools to be developed
shiny and posit connect give us that
ability to in a careful way in a
protected way with user access controls
and a reliable deployment process it
gives us that ability to to have their
projects be shared around the company in
a in a controlled safe responsible way
what started with me kind of playing
with it and and prototyping uh quickly
evolved into a number of Engineers
wanting to get their hands dirty make
their own dashboards do their own data
analysis and explode it really quick to
me what posit connect did for us was was
really brought that that likelihood of
getting value from the investment and
and the time and the expertise in data
science
that shortened that life cycle a lot too
can we can we get this out can we can we
build a consumer-facing product that has
commercial value quickly and cost
efficiently and and try to see if it's
worth it and I'm happy to say that the
solution we've got in place right now
lets us experiment really really fast
it's a lot of fun to be able to kind of
help build this ecosystem around data
not only data when you're hitting balls
on a driving range or that when you're
testing clubs or hitting in a simulator
Bay but more importantly what is your
data on the golf course while you're
playing off and how can you tie those
things together and make better product
decisions custom fitting decisions where
should you be practicing your game where
are you going to get the most leverage
from your practice in your training and
it's still early for us to make those
tools available to a lot of golfers at
scale
looking at
posit and specifically posit connect was
not a short-term solution I I saw it as
a strategic component of a long-term
vision for for digital technology at
ping
if it worked out which I'm really glad
to say it did I don't see that Runway
ending like that that's a foundational
component to how we continue innovating
foreign
[Music]